I guess here's a body revolution
explores the impact of artificial
intelligence on humanity we begin today
with a machine on the moon scientists at
MIT develop a cheetah you will find in
the wild this robotic feline could one
day reach places that are too dangerous
for humans to enter and a Jacobson is on
the MIT campus in Massachusetts with the
first look at the technology behind the
cheetah Dana good morning good morning
MIT will be hosting some of the
brightest minds in technology today at
the first-ever TechCrunch conference the
very latest in artificial intelligence
and robotics will be on display
including this 90-pound four-legged
robot meet cheetah 3 powered by a
complex algorithm made of aluminum if
cheetah is one-of-a-kind in the robot
world chooses less energy than a
microwave runs smoothly and each of her
joints can generate as much power as a
sports car
the hope is one day cheetah will become
the first-ever robot first responder
cheetah can dance yes this wasn't
possible before inspired by the world's
fastest land animal cheetah 3 runs on a
complex computer system and is powered
by customized electric motors bring the
box MIT professor song bake him and his
team have been working on the cheetah
for about seven years when I first
started you know just pure ambition to
build something like a cheetah they can
run and turn fast a lot of people told
me like you're trying to do something
science fiction guided by the animal
world Kim set out to solve one of
robotics biggest challenges mobility
like everybody look at the cheetah it's
oh wow look at that spine we look at the
backbone is bending and exploding this
probably they're fast the machine
cheetah reaches speeds of 30 miles per
hour cheetah 3 has twice as much torque
or rotational force than earlier models
and it's 12 joints give it four times
more flexibility or range of motion
robot cannot actually have as many
muscles and joint like animals because
increasing number of motors too
expensive we need to act
increase the range of motion of each
joints cheetah even responds to commands
powered by Alexa voice technology
welcome to MIT cheetah control and packs
sensors similar to the ones used in
ballistic missiles one day the cheetah
may be used to help care for the elderly
or in disaster relief within five years
Kim thinks the cheetah could be deployed
in dangerous situations like the
Fukushima power plant meltdown
they haven't be able to send anything
they can actually do physical work like
a closing valve or removing degrees many
power plants where radiation level is
high enough that we don't want to send a
human but there are limits to artificial
intelligence
you know wiggle cheetah wasn't in the
right mode to respond to our commands
just part of the learning process and
while you may not be able to take
cheetah home someday you may be able to
3d print a robot that literally walks
out of that printer robots building
robots that's right Rob mccurdy a
postdoctoral associate at MIT can print
this robot in about 24 hours so I can
add the motors he then adds what he
calls the heart and brains of the robot
the battery and the motor you have to
bring this robot to life the computer
may help you create it but it's still
not ready to go that's right I'm
imagining robots like this that are
expendable so maybe they go down in some
really dangerous place or a really
contaminated place do some job they go
down and grab something and move from
one point to another and then the robot
is disposable we have 30 robotics labs
on campus now mi t--'s Toyota professor
of Robotics rust Hedrick says the robot
revolution is limited by a very mundane
reality short battery life so people
think that robots are gonna take over if
we keep teaching and building is that a
fair assumption you can run for more
than about five minutes I think that
there's a natural transition from the
robots in the labs now into the robots
doing meaningful work I think we have to
do that mindfully we have to think a lot
about the implications but I think the
potential for good is just
incredible that you wouldn't want to
stop it you may have heard the comments
by Elon Musk over the weekend that if
artificial intelligence isn't regulated
that it will become a danger to humanity
tomorrow we're going to explore that
idea while we get into humans and robots
working together Jeff we even are gonna
take a look at a brain-controlled robot
Wow Dana thank you so the laws that
surround it I've added that is a big big
point of discussion the next night here
worth discussing it's here yeah
fascinating series more to come tomorrow